in this video I'm going to show an
example of what a budget could look like
and how you might want to modify that
budget depending on your goals your
wants your needs and what you want to
save for so I'm going to do it on a
spreadsheet but you could do a budget on
a piece of paper there's going to be
tools that you could find online that
can also help you set and keep track of
a budget but just on the spreadsheet
here the first thing I start out with is
my after tax income because that's the
actual amount of money that I have to
spend in a given month and I'm going to
do everything here on a monthly basis so
whatever my income was I'm paying for
taxes uh and other things that get
withheld from my paycheck and my after
tax is right here three thousand dollars
now how can you find that out for
yourself you could see that in your pay
stub you could also look in your bank
account if either you're depositing your
pay stops or pay stubs or you're getting
direct deposit this is the amount that
actually is getting deposited in your
account every month if you're getting
paid let's say twice a month and you'd
want to add those two up for the month
now let's think about the needs the
wants and savings now as we talk about
in the introduction video needs are
things that you need that that you know
you need a place to live you need
electricity and water and heating you
probably need some form of
transportation you need probably car
insurance maybe there's other forms of
insurance you need to eat that's where
the groceries come into play you
probably need to communicate with folks
you probably need the Internet maybe to
do your job or just to basically
function in some way and so for this
budget here I've listed all of the need
expenses and they total to
1780 dollars per month now you already
see something interesting going on here
if you take 1780 and divide it by three
thousand dollars you get that it is 59
of this three thousand dollars so
already we are violating the 50 30 20
rule so we're going to look at that a
little bit more but let's just think
about where this budget is right now and
then we can think about how can we tweak
it to get closer to the 50 30 20 Target
now this next column here is our Watts
these are things that are nice to have
so for example you don't have to go to a
restaurant in order to survive you do
have to get groceries eating out at a
restaurant as we know is more expensive
than getting groceries in most cases so
we'll put that as they want so 460
dollars of eating out gym membership
these can be very important but you
don't have to have to have a gym
membership going out entertainment this
might be your streaming services uh you
know that you don't necessarily need to
watch these things this is another form
of entertainment but some of us you know
we we feel like we we we deserve this
type of thing and then I put fancy
clothes here because you probably do
need some clothes but for a lot of us
there might be above and beyond fancy
clothes or things that we might not
absolutely need that I listed here and
all of that combined is 795 dollars and
we're actually doing pretty good on the
50 30 20 rule right over here where
right now our wants are below that 30
percent and then the savings are just
what happened when you take three
thousand dollars subtract 1 780 of needs
subtract 795 dollars of watts and that's
what we are left with but we see that
our savings are not where we want it to
be it's not at that twenty percent and
why is that well because we're
overspending on needs right over here if
we really wanted to meet the 50 30 20
Rule and this is just a rule of thumb
obviously it doesn't have to be exactly
that we would be spending fifteen
hundred dollars on needs nine hundred
dollars on Watts and six hundred dollars
is what we would have saved so let's say
you're this person you're like okay I
really want to get to that 50 30 20 rule
well maybe I can rent a slightly smaller
apartment so maybe I can find another
apartment that costs a little bit less
maybe I can find a cheaper cell phone
plan or well maybe that doesn't get a
lot cheaper I'm still not quite there
maybe I could get a cheaper car maybe I
get a used car of some kind
so maybe something like that I can
economize on my utilities a bit
and I'm almost there and maybe I don't
need the fancier stuff maybe even while
I'm doing my groceries I'm doing a
little bit a few more uh wants and needs
even in that Grocery and this for
example would be a budget that
definitely gets you closer to that 50 30
20. in fact this is now we're now under
budget on needs we're under budget on
wants and now because of that we are
saving more than that 20 percent now
this is not a bad thing as long as you
are living in a sustainable way and
you're getting your needs and we all
deserve some of those wants it's good to
save even more than that 20 it also
shouldn't be a source of stress if maybe
the numbers are a little bit lower than
20 in one month or another the important
thing is is that you're thinking about
this that you're taking your information
for example from your pay stub you're
looking up the information on your bank
account or your credit card statements
to figure out all of these payments
right over here so that you have a good
sense of how much you're spending on
needs how much you're spending on wants
and how much you're spending on savings
I'll tell you if you just go through
this exercise
you will be surprised I encourage you to
think before you do the math where you
think you're spending your money and
then after you do the math see where
you're spending the money and that's
just going to make you that much more
conscientious and give you pretty good
clues of how you might want to modify
your lifestyle in one way or another